i mean i will today i wish him all the
best for him and his family for the
future but i'm glad he's gone because we
need to remember the reasons why he had
to leave office you had the first prime
minister in history that broke the law
one that's lied to parliament one that
illegally shut down parliament so i'm
glad that's over and i hope that liz
trust learns some of the lessons from
that because the language that you
talked about saying that the first
minister of scotland was an attention
seeker we need to have a relationship
where the government in london and the
devolved administrations when it's
appropriate can work together we face
what is the biggest economic crisis that
we've had since the
1970s and we have a responsibility to
make sure that we can reassure the
public and reassure businesses that will
deal with the cost of living crisis
that's the priority that we have today
we need to make sure that we can cap
energy prices but there's going to be a
big debate as to how this is paid it
can't be done on the way of just
deferring bills for people we need to
make sure that government accepts its
responsibilities we're in the situation
we're in
no short measure because of the ukraine
war and of course we stand with ukraine
and the illegal war that putin is
engaging on against them but there's a
price to be paid for that and government
needs to recognize that we need to have
a windfall tax that fairly taxes those
that have benefited from this and we
need to make sure that government puts
its hand in its own pocket and pays for
the cost and crucially if we do this we
can probably knock about four percentage
points off inflation so let's make sure
that we do the right thing let's support
consumers let's support businesses but
now is not the time for having a debate
about tax cuts that would be the wrong
thing to do and i'm looking forward to
having that engagement that debate with
the prime minister over the course of
the next day or two well that's
engagement and debate that's a very
magnanimous way to put it are you
expecting there to be a little bit of a
reset then after what was said during
the leadership
campaign
but there has to be because i think
there's there's got to be a recognition
that the government in edinburgh has got
its job to do and we need to have
appropriate communication with all the
involved administration indeed with the
opposition parties as well we will have
very clear political differences but
there are times that we need to make
sure that when things are happening in
westminster like this it's going to
affect the devolved administrations
affect their budgets no less that
there's a appropriate communication
that's taking place but secondly i think
there's got to be respect for the
devolved administrations and if you take
the position that we are in that we
stood on a commitment of delivering an
independence referendum in the first
half of this parliament the first half
of the scottish parliament and this
trust has got to respect democracy and
has got to respect the right of the
scottish parliament to allow people in
scotland to have a say on their
constitutional future
now of course there are reports this
morning that uh this trust is planning
some kind of change legislation to make
it more difficult for an independent
referendum to be held of course there is
going to be a hearing at the high court
all about the legality of a next
independence referendum where do you
stand on what you're hearing these
reports about
this trust and her potential plans
well let me say it's barking mad it's i
think what we refer to as gerrymandering
when you stand for an election and when
you have a referendum you put your case
you encourage the electorate to vote and
of course you want to have the highest
turnout possible but the idea that
somehow or other you can change the
rules
i think people in scotland whether or
not they agree with us or not are going
to reflect on what is you know a silent
behavior which is just completely
unacceptable and if you think about the
the rules that
liz trust and our government are
thinking of putting in place that means
for example that brexit wouldn't have
happened because you weren't able to
clear that hard deal you'd be left in a
situation where those on the electoral
roll that sadly may have passed on would
effectively be counted as a new voter in
such a contest it's not right it's wrong
and this should be put to bed we should
simply not be
tolerating or considering these things
what we need to recognize is the
scottish parliament has a mandate to
deliver a referendum my message to this
trust is she needs now to sit down with
the first minister of scotland and
negotiate the terms of that referendum
to make sure it can take place in the
timeline that the scottish government
has indicated which is a referendum in
october 2023 i regret that we're having
to go to the supreme court but we're
having to go to the supreme court
because the government in london
wouldn't recognize that people in
scotland have that right to determine
their own future
yeah and the courts will make that
ruling in due course won't they but i
mean i'll pick you up on this blackfoot
you know gone from this sort of reset
where you hope that there's
relationships gonna be better to
describing the plan as barking mad and
there's obviously there's a bit of
friction there isn't there and there is
a coming to heads coming to ahead pretty
soon between uh you guys and the
incoming prime minister well it's about
democracy and it's about fair play and
the idea that you can gerrymander the
rules for a referendum is simply not
right and i think people not just in
scotland right across the united kingdom
will will recognize that and i think
there has to be a degree of common sense
and rationality when we're having these
discussions
black but of course this trust says she
wants to keep the union together and
that is her stated position
so
i mean how do you expect this to play
out
i i respect anybody that wants to argue
the case for the union and they should
do that and that's a a much more
rational debate whether it's liz trust
or the scottish conservatives or
scottish labour let them lay out their
case as to how they see scotland in the
union and i want to have that debate
because i want to be able to showcase
what we can deliver with independence i
want to make sure that we can accelerate
our green energy production and do that
for the purpose of making sure that we
can generate the investment that's
required to deliver a green industrial
future for scotland of course we need to
deal with the problems for brexit and
we're paying a price for that and for us
i mean the clear demonstration of the
will of the people of scotland is to be
back in the european union so i look
forward to having that debate let's have
that respectful debate of what is in the
best interest of the people of scotland
but let's not have this this silly
debate about changing the electoral
rules let's treat people with respect
actually let's have that debate about
how we improve the lives of people that
live in the country of scotland